so you have a new venture right well
let's share it's sharing information
I've become so frustrated with so many
terrific pieces of work and so many
amazing creative people not being able
to get their work out there and I've
identified the reason is it's just hard
to know how you do it it's hard to know
what the pathway is so in my work
I'll grant that you are creative and you
have something terrific to share I'm not
doing artists way workshops I'm not
doing things to help you motivate your
creativity what I am doing is helping
you learn the path to get your work out
there and it's not as though the path to
get your work out there is really you
know held by secret cabal's with special
handshakes but it's not really openly
talked about it's not really openly
shared there's no one central database
that you can go to to find out the
information it's kind of why you're
doing what you're doing you're trying to
to go out interview people get the
information and get it out there so
people can know about it and I'm trying
to do exactly the same thing so I'm
taking the information that I have
learned from my years in theatre and
film as an executive as a producer as a
distributor and also all the amazing
information that I've learned from the
amazing people that I've been privileged
to work with and I have studied them and
I've studied what has made them
successful and I've studied what has
worked and I've studied what has not
worked and I've done things that have
worked that I've done things that have
not worked and I've tried to put it
together in a way that it's just really
digestible understandable repeatable and
this is the thing it's repeatable I
think you know if you know that there
are steps you will always get to a
result the result may not be the result
you hoped for it may not be under
million dollars an Academy Award but you
will get a results and the result will
inform what you do next it will help you
inform your work will help you make your
work better maybe the work that you're
working on
right now and maybe your next work so
that's really what I'm doing now
you